[Musique]
le samedi 24 septembre dans notre ville
on va faire la journée des découvertes
de la Mauritanie
[Musique]
c'est une journée de manifestation
culturelle et artistique qui promo qui
Prome les produits artisanaux et les
produits touristiques de la Bretagne
les visiteurs ont donc libre choix de
venir dans le pôle Molière dans le parc
Molière non seulement pour y découvrir
la Mauritanie dans tous ces aspects et
sa diversité il y aura de la musique
traditionnelle des danses
traditionnelles dans la salle lumière on
aura donc des grandes artistes
Mauritania dans le parc mondial on verra
donc une tente qu'on appelle lahma chez
les mauritanien qui est donc l'habitat
nomade où il y aura donc une une
exposition artisanale l'artisan
l'artisanat de la Mauritanie
[Musique]
dans le parc Molière nous aurons donc la
chance d'avoir six chameliers avec des
chameaux on va se balader dans le parc
Molière on pourra prendre des photos et
on sera dans un cadre ou pratiquement le
désert et là on pourra faire donc des
balades avec notre nos enfants notre
famille et surtout découvrir cet animal
qui est l'emblème de la Mauritanie